Hello I'm a citizen. And I'm the
government.
So do you work for me or are you like my dad?
Just think of me as the things that we do together.
Together.
Hello I'm a citizen. And I'm the
government.
Hey it's tax season, how much do I owe
you guys?
Oh you have to figure that out for yourself.
Do you know how much I owe
you?
Oh yeah we know, but we're not gonna tell
you, you have to figure it out.
What happens if I get it wrong?
Well then you owe us more, and you might go to prison.
Hello I'm a citizen. And I'm the
government.
Hey you guys outlawed marijuana.
Yes, it is worse than cocaine.
Uh, can I see some studies to back that up?
You know it's real hard to find scientific studies on that kind of subject.
Because you outlawed it?
Yes it is worse than cocaine.
Hello I'm a citizen. And I'm the
government.
Hey I'm social distancing and I wanted to check to see if you'd resolve those testing issues.
I'm sorry I don't know which ones you're talking about.
The...tests that the CDC screwed up?
Yeah you're going to need to be a bit more specific.
How many tests did the CDC screw up?
I can't--I can't hear you, I can't hear because of the Blue Angels--look at that--flying over.
Oh that's so cool!
You're welcome.